primero es importante tener en cuenta
que estas decisiones se tienen que tomar
por consenso absoluto una pequeña
diferencia de opiniones puede bloquear
cualquier decisión los documentos que sí
se han firmado es la carta
medioambiental también conocida como
pacto verde que da los lineamientos a
los 22 países de la comunidad
iberoamericana para tener en cuenta Cómo
deben luchar no Cuáles son las líneas
generales contra el cambio climático
también la ruta crítica contra la
inseguridad alimentaria un mal al que
aqueja a muchos países de esta región y
muy de la mano con la carta anterior
porque de hecho la producción agrícola
emite el 45% de los gases invernaderos
en la región latinoamericana también se
firmó un documento de derechos digitales
para cerrar la brecha digital en los
países de América Latina el documento
que no se firmó finalmente fue el de la
arquitectura financiera que pedía los
países latinoamericanos pedían a
estructuras internacionales como el fmi
o el Banco Mundial más facilidad para
acceder a créditos a préstamos
internacionales que les ayudarán también
a salir más rápidamente las crisis
económicas que atraviesan pero
finalmente ese documento se cayó France
24 de hecho lo avanzamos ya ayer
entonces sin embargo abinader el
presidente de República Dominicana que
es el huésped de esta Cumbre confirmó en
una rueda de prensa que habían sido
problemas más de forma que de fondo y
que los ministros de Hacienda los
ministros de economía iban a seguir
trabajando en este documento en los
próximos meses con la intención de que
aunque no se haya llegado a un acuerdo
en esta Cumbre se llegue en el futuro
bien y ahora Rosa Pese a que se trató de
dar una especie de unidad se
evidenciaron también diferentes
divisiones dentro del bloque cuéntenos
Qué sucedió al respecto
pues Andrés Bueno buenas noches es un
gusto También saludarte les cuento Que
durante la ronda de discursos que ha
empezado esta mañana de los jefes de
gobierno y de estado asistentes aquí a
la Cumbre iberoamericana cada uno de los
mandatarios ha aprovechado como es
habitual para hacer un alegato de su
visión digamos de la región y del mundo
y en particular hablar también de su
país en este contexto ha habido varios
episodios en los que hemos visto hemos
presenciado críticas cruzadas entre
distintos países no la primera ha sido
por pronunciada por parte del presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro quien ha dicho
bien al principio de su discurso que
cómo podíamos aplaudir que Venezuela
haya vaya a regresar al sistema
interamericano de derechos humanos y que
al mismo tiempo la comunidad
latinoamericana no condene literalmente
que un presidente que debería aquí en
referencia a la Cumbre iberoamericana
esté en prisión a preventiva en una
alusión directa al presidente al
expresidente peruano Pedro Castillo por
otro lado cuando ha sido el turno ya más
adelante de la canciller de Perú quien
está en representación del país dado que
la presidenta Dina boluarte ha sido una
de las ausencias destacadas a esta
Cumbre bien cuando ha sido el turno
entonces de Ana María gervasi Ella ha
respondido directamente a Petro ha dicho
que si Pedro Castillo no está aquí es
porque dio un golpe de estado y que si
estuviera presente ha dicho de lo
contrario tendrían ustedes aquí a un
dictador otro episodio la protagonizado
la crítica Cruzada entre el presidente
de chileno Gabriel borich y el canciller
de Nicaragua Dennis Moncada ha empezado
Gabriel borics durante su discurso
también y Era el principio diciendo que
si bien hay que respetarla no injerencia
en de otros países la comunidad no se
puede callar quedar callada ha dicho no
se puede callar delante de la dictadura
familiar de Daniel Ortega estas han sido
sus palabras ha dicho también En
referencia a las a trescientas personas
a las que Nicaragua ha despojado de
nacionalidad que sabe muy bien Daniel
Ortega que la patria se lleva en el alma
y no se puede quitar por decreto bien
cuando ha sido Entonces el turno de la
canciller de Nicaragua él ha hecho una
ilusión directa al presidente chileno ha
dicho pedimos a borich Que respete al
estado al gobierno y al pueblo de
Nicaragua y ha dicho que no esconda su
digamos su tradición al sentimiento
latinoamericano y caribeño y su
rendición ante Estados Unidos en las
críticas a Nicaragua y solo para
terminar recordemos que ayer en el que
el día en que se reunieron los
cancilleres los ministros de exteriores
también hubo un episodio protagonizado
por el canciller de Bolivia y por el
canciller de En qué les preguntaron
respecto así sus países digamos iban
continuaban condicionando la retoma de
relaciones a la cuestión del acceso de
Bolivia al mar en todo caso el
presidente chileno Gabriel boric y él de
Bolivia Luis Arce mantuvieron una
reunión bilateral y finalmente hoy Luis
Arce cuando ha sido su turno de
pronunciar el discurso no ha hecho una
referencia directa a esta histórica
reivindicación del acceso de Bolivia al
mar así que bueno estas son algunas de
las cuestiones más destacables las
principales discrepancias que se han
hecho evidentes aquí durante esta Cumbre
iberoamericana